tuvo y tu amigo jeremías están pescando
en un estanque que contiene 10 truchas y
10 cercas cada vez que uno de los dos
atrapa un pescado lo regresan al
estanque jeremías te da la posibilidad
de escoger entre dos apuestas diferentes
apuesta 1 apuesta 1 y menos aliento a
apostar pero parece que jeremías quiere
apostar si los tres próximos pescados
que el atrape son percas tu le pagaras a
él 100 dólares si no él te pagará a ti
20 dólares apuesta 2 si tú atrapas al
menos dos cercas dentro de los próximos
tres pescados que atrapen
él te pagará 50 dólares si no tú le
pagaras a él 25 dólares cuál es tu valor
esperado de la apuesta 1 redondea tu
respuesta a centavos
los invito a detener el vídeo a intentar
resolverlo por su cuenta entonces veamos
el valor esperado de la apuesta 1 el
valor esperado de digamos de la apuesta
a 1
la apuesta 1 es y mejor definamos una
variable aleatoria para hacerlo más
fácil así que digamos que
es igual
y lo
así lo podemos decir porque es probable
que obtengas algo lo que
gas
nada
de la apuesta a uno
cuesta
es una variable aleatoria entonces el
valor esperado de x el valor esperado
será igual
y veamos cuál es la probabilidad serán
será será menos 100 dólares por la
probabilidad de que atrape tres peces
entonces la probabilidad de que jeremías
as
p
las próximas tres serán cercas por 100
dólares por
debería decir vas a pagar esto así que
como tú lo estás pagando lo pondré como
menos
para decir que esta es tu ganancia
esperada o sea perderás dinero con eso
qué
esta será 1 - esta probabilidad
la probabilidad de que
as
p
en esta situación él te pagará a ti 20
dólares
tú obtienes
20 dólares entonces la parte importante
aquí es encontrar la probabilidad de que
jeremías atrape tres cercas las cercas
son 10 de los 20 pescados entonces en
cualquier momento que intenta atrapar un
pescado hay 10 veinteavos o un medio de
probabilidades de que sea una perca
entonces la probabilidad de que atrape 3
cercas seguidas
me dio
x
me dio por
y medio y ellos regresan los peces al
estanque y es por eso que la
probabilidad se queda como 10 de 20 si
no regresarán a los peces entonces para
el segundo pescado tendría 9 de 20
probabilidades de que el segundo sea una
perca pero en este caso están regresando
los peces cada vez que los atrapan
entonces hay una probabilidad de un
octavo de que jeremías atrape 3
entonces esto de aquí es
8º
1 - un octavo son 7
octavos entonces tienes una probabilidad
de un octavo de pagar 100 dólares y una
probabilidad de siete octavos de ganar
veinte dólares por lo que esto nos dan
esto nos da entonces nuestra ganancia
esperada digamos sera
8º
de que pierda 100 dólares por menos
pero después hay
davos de probabilidad de que ganes que
ganes y dejen de poner un paréntesis
aquí para facilitar el orden de las
operaciones la calculadora debería de
hacerse cargo pero lo pondré aquí de
todas maneras siete octavos hay siete
octavos de probabilidad de que obtengas
veinte dólares entonces tu ganancia
esperada aquí es de más cinco dólares
entonces tu ganancia esperada aquí es
igual
5 dólares
y este es el valor esperado de la
apuesta 1
ahora pensemos en la apuesta 2 apuesta 2
si tú atrapas al menos dos cercas dentro
de los próximos tres pescados que
atrapen él te pagará 50 dólares si no tú
le pagaras a él 25 dólares
pensemos en la probabilidad de atrapar
al menos 2 percas de los próximos tres
peces que atrapen y hay muchas maneras
en que podemos pensar esto pero debido a
que solo tienes tres oportunidades para
atrapar a los pescados podemos escribir
todos los posibles resultados que son
posibles aquí podrías obtener cerca
cerca cerca cuál es el otro tipo de
pescado que se tiene así la trucha
tienes cerca perca trucha puedes tener
cerca trucha cerca
puedes tener cerca trucha trucha puedes
tener trucha cerca cerca
puedes tener trucha cerca trucha puedes
tener trucha trucha
puedes tener trucha trucha trucha y
podemos ver aquí que cada vez que pescas
hay hay dos posibilidades entonces cada
vez que intentas atrapar un pescado hay
dos posibilidades entonces si lo haces
tres veces tienes dos por dos por dos
posibilidades hay un
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
posibilidades entonces dentro de estas
ocho posibilidades igualmente probables
cuántas de ellas involucran que tú
atrapas al menos dos percas entonces tú
atrapas al menos dos perchas
aquí
en esta otra
y creo que sólo en esas sí sí así es
está solo es un uppercut una cerca una
perca en ninguna perca entonces en
cuatro de las ocho probabilidades
igualmente probables atrapas al menos
dos cercas
tu probabilidad de atrapar al menos dos
cercas probabilidad de atrapar
cas
cercas s
buzz
medio entonces veamos cuál es el valor
esperado
la ganancia esperada de la apuesta 2
entonces de igual a esta es otra
variable igual a la ganancia
esperada
apuesta
2 entonces
en valor
esperado
de la variable aleatoria
tienes un medio de probabilidad de que
ganes entonces tienes un medio de
probabilidad de ganar
50 dólares y después tienes el otro un
medio de probabilidad tienes un medio de
ganar y habrá un 1 - un medio de
probabilidad de ganar lo que es
medio de probabilidad de perder entonces
tienes un medio de probabilidad de tener
que pagar 25 dólares así que veamos
cuánto es esto es un medio por 50 más un
medio por menos 25 esto será 25 menos
12.5 menos 12.5 lo que es igual a
12.5 entonces el valor esperado de la
apuesta 2 es
12.5
tu amigo te dice que él está dispuesto
está dispuesto a apostar el combinado de
las dos apuestas máximo 50 veces en
total
si quieres maximizar tu valor esperado
que haces la apuesta a 2 bueno de hecho
las dos son buenas apuestas ya que tu
amigo no es tan sofisticado pero la
apuesta 2 tiene un valor esperado más
alto
entonces yo tomaría la apuesta 2 todo el
tiempo entonces yo tomaría la apuesta 2
todo el tiempo